Kameron I'd like to ask if we remain in
the EU
how will you and how can you control
immigration right very important
question Bob we can control immigration
from outside the EU in the way we do now
by closing down these bogus colleges and
we've closed down about 800 of them and
we can do it by having a cap on
migration for economic reasons coming
into the country well can you get that
date I'm going to do it inside the EU
the key changes that I'm going to make
if you reelect me of these first of all
anyone coming from an EU country cannot
claim unemployment benefit while they're
looking for a job
second if they're here after six months
and haven't got a job they have to go
home third you have to work here for
four years pay into the system before
you get tax credits and other benefits
out of the system and fourth if you're
living here but your family's back at
home you will no longer be able to send
the Child Benefit home to your family
now those four changes are big changes
and they'll make a real difference and
help us to control immigration if I'm
Prime Minister that's what you'll get
just a couple of points I'm sure a lot
of you have questions on this but a
couple bites first of all we looked at
the figures of this under six percent of
EU nationals living in this country
claimed benefits of any kind under six
percent but I'm not saying what you're
saying no stopping that is going to huge
l'énergie so number and the other thing
is let me ask that one no that's
important but right well point I say is
it's the in work benefits at the moment
someone coming from an EU country is
effectively getting around eight
thousand pounds to come and work here
now I'm not saying they shouldn't be
able to come and work here
British people can go and work in other
European countries but we do have a
benefit system that skews it in favor of
people coming to work here that needs to
change now that need change in Europe
and so you need a prime minister that's
prepared to get changing you may come to
your either do we come yeah I hope we do
too but